okay we're on overtime what will be the
fallout from the rolling stone
retraction of its rape on campus story
what yes well it's a real unfortunate
thing because rape in America is an
important issue and they somehow found
the one fraternity on the one night
where there wasn't a rape that's that's
not how I would put it but of course
it's it's a collective failure in
journalism and it has to be built
journalism has to be built on trust
right the trust of the source the trust
of the reporter of the editor the trust
of the people above that and every level
of this when you read the forensic
account of what happened in that story I
can't understand how it made publication
you as an editor we make these tough
decisions all the time but it has
changed the conversation about rape
where it should actually no conversation
but you can you can understand how it
made publication because I mean it was
the biggest story in just about anything
for about two and a half weeks and
clearly I mean I completely agree with
you about you know that it was a
complete [ __ ] show from beginning to end
in terms of in terms of what they were
what they were doing but but they you
know they thought the lead the lead for
the story the suit was just too good it
was too good the lesson the lesson is
you can't you can't work backwards from
the result you want that's what we did
with Iraq isn't it you know they wanted
to find weapons of mass that was quite a
segue so dick Channing I gotta say that
was really but it's kind of true why
Dick Cheney was like find me a guy who
thinks there's weapons of mass
destruction and Rolling Stone was like
this is an issue the difference is that
this really is an issue when they
weren't really any weapon that there
were alarm bells you know that yeah a
reporter and the editor had and nobody
did it yeah well how could they not how
can nobody be fired as a result of this
that's what I don't understand how
because there's Lee I think because
there's legal liability they're scared
that they fire someone they're admitting
that they will they never publish
another story by that reporter well they
have no that's the thing if they don't
publish another story then they have
effectively fired her and that could be
taken as evidence put all the blame on
her either I mean really was layer after
layer after layer whether they had
fallen down I I didn't put a fair amount
yeah I said most of it I mean that right
I mean she was certainly culpable of
lying
oh I'm talking about the reporter
oh the reporters and she specifically
said you know no one no one pushed me to
ask these three people or their real
information or detract are you supposed
to know that in a newspaper called The
Daily local news in West Chester
Pennsylvania tiny paper we want to ran a
headline woman beats off would-be
rapists that's how that's the kind of
newspaper a while we're in front-page
pictures of zucchini we would never have
printed that story and I don't know of
anybody who would if that's what I'm
saying though how how can how can you
not anyway that's a great headline Dave
it's a true headline I didn't really I
didn't write it yet woman beats off
would-be rapists nobody noticed it till
it was too late what is the impact of
Obama's recent announcement calling for
an end to conversion therapies yes
that's the pray away the gay right this
is the belief that you can pray away gay
and then the president to his creditors
coming out and saying come on that this
is this is crazy you cannot pray away
the gay
hey work for me is that how you can
straight say I'm just trying to be a
part of the panel and it's on me to
participate comes at the same time the
White House has a gender neutral
restroom I mean the president is trying
to set it right people there and the
employees in the White House have
actually said you know they feel like he
is trying to leave there and perhaps
that will catch on I mean you can liken
it to the minimum wage debate or you
know some of the other things he's
trying to do but it's certainly a way to
what is the view of the conservatives
you know those those reviews avión on
praying away the gay well first of all
the conversion therapy stuff some of it
is weak or [ __ ] Freudianism rather
than pret you know sort of prayer based
it's sort of a holdover from 14 theories
of homosexuality and I think the
consensus is it doesn't work and it's
what was generally view on homosexual
Freud's is this how much time do we have
on overtime Freud had already had a lot
of views on homosexuality but boy
weighed down I mean the Freudian take
was well or at least the interpretation
of the Freudian take was that you know I
think he called homosexuality inversion
and he liked everything with Freud he's
connected it to issues with your mother
here and your father there and so on and
so the argument was you know you have a
distant father and a domineering mother
and so you grow up to be gay and this
was sort of a strain in psychotherapy
for a long time and it was picked up by
some social and religious conservatives
I think starting the 60s and 70s anyway
it's a longer story but that's that's
that's all right boiled egg good here I
mean I'm a little skeptical about I
think there's a distinction here between
what parents do to kids and what adults
do there are you know it's a free
country and they're gay adults who want
to go to a therapist who can who talked
to them about becoming straight and
that's reality and it's a free country
and okay I don't think it's the
president's place necessarily to say I
mean I yeah I don't think it's the
president's place to say what consenting
adults can do with their therapist as a
private life is also I think what it's
getting at is that under the under the
radar very overt discrimination against
gays there is a lot of this kind of
stuff that gays have to put up with that
that I think he's trying to change the
culture
not so much proposed a big new law I
think and I think it is true that there
is a lot of this kind of below the radar
stuff that is directed towards gays that
you know makes makes life hard and and I
think the government has always had a
role in saying about any health
supplement that's phony wouldn't they
point that out and say this is just
sawdust in this pill it's not real and
there's no there's no evidence that it
works
well but with no other worries are there
any issues of like forty and therapy
honestly if you want to get into it
saying the government needs to start
regulating whether talk these nowhere
therapy works or not then you're going
to open like six layers of I mean
there's no evidence that forty and your
Jungian therapy works generally right I
mean that's you know that's an extreme
statement but if you had the FDA
regulating Union Union therapists you'd
put it into a ridiculous urgently what I
both you're going to get a lot of emails
some psycho yeah you and I both know
that Obama's really an atheist so I mean
he could have said prayer doesn't work
at all am I getting at Scott Walker but
I don't know I don't say that I think
Obama is a liberal Christian but a
Christian so okay so Fareed is our
recent obsession with STEM education
misguided oh yes now here's something we
agree on liberal education I think
that's fantastic that you're stick
taking the banner for that
I got a liberal education I was an
English major I use English in my career
and and we have forgotten all these
subjects and that's one reason why we're
so in such a mess politically people
don't take history they don't take
civics they don't know anything okay and
and I think there's a mistake the
mistaken view that the only way you can
get a job or do well you know
professionally is to do this kind of
stem stem is great if you're interested
in science of course you should follow
your passion but there are many many
ways to live a productive working life
there are lots of people who have
English degrees history history degrees
and the truth of the matter is what your
second or third or fifth or sixth job is
going to have so little to do with what
you trained for that what you want are
these broad basic skills that can last
you for your whole life in your working
life but also you know about other lives
as well as a parent is it as a reader as
a as a you know as a friend this is
something that helps you it with all of
that but the most important thing I
think people worry so much about is you
can these these broad-based skills
actually are more portable as the
economy changes because that's the stuff
you don't know what industry you're
going to be in 20 years from now but you
know that you're going to need to think
clearly express yourself clearly work
with other people you know those kind of
comments can what happened to the idea
of the Renaissance man you know
with the most interesting man in the
world dude you know don't we all want to
be like him yeah and you know he's a
history major yeah okay does the panel
of any expectations for Obama's meeting
with Raul Castro Fareed look I think
it's terrific they are trying after
after you know five decades of isolation
we're trying to see whether commerce and
capitalism and trade will change Cuba
more than isolation and sanctions and
threats because I'd enter in a way I
think I'm the capitalist here you know I
think I I think give give the Cuban
people a taste of the of the world that
they have missed out on and you will see
the you know the it will be the acid
that will dissolve this dictatorship
over time could have done this 50 years
ago and today Cuba would be st. Barths
I'm Jay Z would be partying this this
was one of the presidents that's a
candidate yes was one of his issues
against Hillary Clinton saying you know
it was a different Castro but saying you
know yes I would sit down and talk to
him and talk to Ahmed Dean Assad and
this was sort of his point on the list
on the list of dictators that we have
done business with they were about a
hundred on the list as far as awfulness
but actually I mean do you think like
that I don't have particularly have a
problem with the opening to Cuba but I
don't think we should kid ourselves
necessarily that capitalism is actually
a solvent of dictatorships I mean we've
been making that argument with China for
the last butter's years and i mean i
saina is much freer than it was thirty
years ago I mean I've been going to
China 2020 ideas and it people have the
ability to own property they can move
they can get the job down these are all
real freedoms you know that but I mean
Rusted the freedom to own property is
freedom I agree work is freed I'm just
saying the dictatorship itself all
little benefits from managing the
opening right and this is this day
you're near your night I live in Miami
my wife is Cuban my way oh really is
actually Cuban Jewish juban they yes
that's what they called they didn't that
income on rafts they parted the
Caribbean but they are but my wife is
Cuban her family all fled Castro I know
many Cubans Miami people that you know
they're viewed as fanatics they're not
the second generation third generation
like my wife they it they're much more
realistic but there's there's one thing
they all agree on which is yes good
let's you know open we're already
sitting Cubans are sending a lot of
money down there anywhere as it is but
nobody in Miami believes that the
Castro's are going to give up any power
whatsoever nobody believes that it's
going to get any better politically or
over a long time and that the people who
believe that are very nice they're both
very old the Castro's but they've got
all these thugs working for them they've
got a whole apparatus is about
dictatorships is when it they're in
place you think that they go on forever
and then when they collapse you always
think God why did I was it able to stay
so you talk about all these
dictatorships we've seen about dha'fi
people like that now died in China still
whatever China is the most successful
economic development in human history
Cuba is not right good okay
stay put is the secret to your youthful
hair well and do you work in want to ask
that all night and you worry about young
guy hair old guy face is that something
that you is that a concern
because well that is a no we know it's
real it's very I get accused of not
having real hair but thank you Larry
give me this opportunity on television
to say no this is my [ __ ] hair this
is my haircut Avidan Aamir Khan oh yeah
I know it's amazing it is a freak of
nature all right Thank You panel thank
you
you